welcome to this video this is a new
rapid game yeah 15 minute chess on ice
you see let's see what happens I'm
bringing playing wfm cute yeah nice name
is no name no real name in them okay
1.e4 is what she played on okay maybe do
something else Alec Owens defends let's
see what I get from this not in opening
that I know a lot about but I've played
it sometimes about let's say 15 years
ago okay this is the chase variation I
don't think this is really great but ah
you six or c6 i think ii 6 i'm not
totally sure yeah i guess white will
play d4 now d 4 and then I was intending
and 10 intended to play be 6v6 looks
quite nice
okay so why does taking a time on I
think I think there's also something
like Bishop c4 but not totally sure that
they are gambit ideas where white gives
up a pawn on c5 and cash is taking quite
a long time what I ratings anyway in the
other pools and not many games played at
all mostly some five minute okay hmm
that's really a long thing that early in
the opening I mean you go D for what
what else Bishop c4 on night XD five way
hmm yeah that's not a very economical
way to use the time but yeah I'm not the
world's greatest expert in time
management in online blitz myself not
that bad in tournament chess them
normally head on the clock but here I
come on let's play a move here I want to
get a game going is this some connection
issue no it's not mmm how much time is
this for this roof like two minutes more
than two minutes spent for with six now
and if why does suddenly and realizing
that the c5 porn is somewhat exposed
then it's a bit late I mean what can
easily keep the porn with deform I guess
I would play b6 after d4
if this this must be a connection issue
the pingas is quite good but Jeff I
don't know yeah now move I send an abort
request because I thought there might be
some some issue but then she played a
move where you read ok let's see what
happens mhm ok so i can in true style of
this opening i can play against the
center successfully I think c64 Bishop a
6 is quite good yeah why not it's a
stable sender and the bishop a 6 is a is
a nice move to get in this night on b8
is an issue but it can maybe develop can
be given up via a 62 e6a 6076 ultimately
bishop here i am i was wondering if i
should just check on a 5 get the Queen's
off check I think this is a good idea
the structure should be quite nice for
me especially with Queens traded the
porn see'em are somewhat of a liability
i think ii five and c5 okay that's
interesting if i take and play a five
what is White's reply white can hardly
play a 3 B 5 are just take for a pond
and takes rook takes looks really ugly
okay I'm going to grab and try to claim
that i'm just a pawn up which from a
purely arithmetic appoint of view is
certainly true i am upon up okay so I
guess Ruby age to secure the palm and be
50 yeah hmm well they keep the King
moves the d5 pawn of course is not very
strong is there some way to to secure
this pawn
and how do I get the HD to look into
play
hmm that's not not that easy actually
King c3 I will have a FB form and you
can also go to eat too huh okay maybe we
should be seven and then f six or
something not easy not easy to continue
here I mean it's not a huge issue if I
lose this back the device okay she is
basically ignoring this idea i can just
castle now or take on take on d4 no
that's not good let's just cancel and
get this routine to play everything else
fails I can still just walk back to the
center with the King a possible
continuation now is root Wow whoopsie
eight isn't this already a bit of a
problem I can I know not taking then he
has nicer than she has 93 but this
threatens 94 now King takes and then the
capture simply if six was also might not
that strong what now this is ok this is
ok I guess rook see one now
nope hmm ok takes Knight takes rook see
where there is some sunlight at five
business and d5 is weak so I see ya
that's maybe not one hundred percent
clear the bishop cannot move anyway so I
mean if it if white goes to be two or
something i take c 5 Bishop e3 atg5 so
that's not not a problem and maybe just
98 to e6 em yeah maybe or Bishop g5 2f
form but rookie one as possible ok let's
play some some strengthening moves night
the 86 as mush as another idea maybe
there already was some syntactic
available oh this I didn't didn't
recognize that all this idea oh wow
Bishop g5 I guess what white can maybe
fight with 95 gaming up an exchange if
she allows me to take on his six yeah
this is not very nice
let's see maybe before even takes root
chicks yeah no root X and stating the
line and then I'm entering a wrong
premium but good yeah right now has huge
coordination issues I'm getting in d4 or
hear the trade yeah I can just take d4
and takes you five yeah it's probably
wins but stairs some other move 1944
Roxy five yeah yeah come on keep it
simple this is some this is how many
points six points two points here and i
have the the good rook position here on
b5 supporting the pawn from behind okay
now i just need to get the king into the
game over here to e6 so that i have d 6
at some point to get rid of my double
pawn
check yeah this is ultimately a zoosk
bug problem as the rook or the King has
to move and then the endgame is is very
easy what is easiest here I guess not
moving one of the pawns at all is
easiest just waiting for white to get
out of run out of moves
oh the rook moves I go v3 the King moves
I go King c5
yeah that's pretty pretty easy now I
guess no one counter play whatsoever on
a king move i now have king e 5s while
winning the f5 pawn my sis check here
but it's not really really a threat
check rugby 119 d6
white resides yeah let's have a recap of
this game she resigned the weirdest part
was the early early long thing here in
this situation almost three minutes okay
wherever be six this all looked fairly
fairly normal white took until I really
thought that yeah white would take on b6
but this was played and I captured 26
well here I like the position but it's
nothing special yet the compounds to
play before words now that does make
some sense just before grabbing space
mmm why not this is probably helping me
I a night a 6 already a good move but
Jackie I just wanted to check get rid of
the greens and trade this Bishop off for
a simple position before yeah before was
AG as a mistake why just place here this
is much better actually because the
night and the bishop they both compete
for the a 6 a-6 square and it's not
clear what my booth is now maybe this
means that this Bishop a 6 concept
wasn't that great now why does find him
probably have to play Bishop e7 back and
then first we route the night and only
then get the bishop back ok this was
helping like quite clearly takes and
here this this move I don't know I mean
white also could have tried this using
the King Joe to snatch the d5 pawn it's
not clear at all yeah Here I am keeping
the pawn for
time being and I'm just better are
playing many computer moves here ya hear
the computer wants to grab but I wasn't
sure about this here actually there is a
case where I probably can just grab yeah
yeah I should have taken taken the pawn
but ok this keeps things under control
and here I thought she should probably
try to sacrifice the exchange somehow
try to go for this sorry six but it's
ultimately not sufficient I can even
just cover this yeah ok here I'm just
grabbing only three end this now is
healthy fairly easy the bishop is very
clumsy on deform and i will enter here
with my my pieces with decisive effect
this is not the best way probably to
play by the rookie end game with two
pauses is quite quite convincing check
ya hear it's very simple technical play
yeah I hope you enjoyed this rapid game
thanks for watching